avant de débuter ce journal toute
l'équipe de tv 78 et moi même vous
souhaitons une très belle année 2010 8
pleine de réussite et de santé surtout
c'est le plus important
récurrent en cette période nous prenons
nos bonnes résolutions après avoir si à
nous les tenons ou pas et en ce début
2010 8 quelles sont les résolutions
prises par les saint quentinois propos
recueillis par patrick jacques de
dixmude aujourd'hui pas pris non comme
ça je suis sûr de les tenir pour la
santé peut-être faire du sport ouais
mais je me le dis tous les ans j'espère
que cette année ça va marcher au pas la
santé ins et primeurs bien là c'est tout
simplement de prendre plus de temps de
de vivre ma vie de famille parce qu'on
essaie toujours travail travail travail
travail est d'essayer voilà d'aider un
petit peu plus les autres parce que je
pense que on est dans un monde on est
très égoïste de continuer à ne rien
faire puisque je suis à la retraite
la santé la famille et puis et ça me
suffit
mais je les prends tous les jours mes
résolutions alors je vais vous dire je
vois pas pourquoi il faut absolument que
ce soit le 1er janvier vous voyez oui
oui moi je veux rester jeune et beau
absolument pas je ne prends jamais de
résolution c'est la manière le meilleure
manière pour ne pas avoir ne pas les
suivre donc pas de résolution et tout va
bien j'espère que 2018 sera aussi bien
que 2017 et aussi bien que 2010 9 ans